I'm Dr David Katz let's answer some
questions from the internet this is
nutrition support
[Music]
Curtis M Whitaker in your opinion what
is the best diet for Health and
Longevity it's a theme it's not one
specific diet seven words eat food not
too much mostly plants and that comes to
us courtesy of the blue zones five
populations around the world in ikoria
Greece Sardinia Italy Okinawa Japan Loma
Linda California and the nicoya
peninsula in Costa Rica where people
most often live to be a hundred years
old don't get chronic disease or
dementia they all adhere to that same
basic theme real food mostly plants lots
of vegetables fruits whole grains beans
lentils nuts and seeds mostly plain
water when thirsty aim to love the food
that loves you back if that's the
foundation of your diet you can't go too
far wrong at J Hartman 24 asks can you
have too much protein yes you can eat
too much protein most Americans get
about twice the recommended amount of
protein excess protein is acidic X
excess protein can't be used by the body
doesn't turn into big strong muscles the
body can store carbohydrate and it can
store fat it cannot store protein our
carbohydrate store is called glycogen
generally about 1200 to 1800 calories
worth protein does not get stored so
what the body does is convert it into
something it can store and since
glycogen is already capped out all
Surplus protein the body doesn't need
and can't use now it stores this fat at
EXO baby doll 9 ask where does keto
science and nutrition come from how does
anyone believe that eating zero carbs
and almost all fat could be good for you
it doesn't make sense to me so where
does it come from is there a science Yes
actually so the origins of the ketogenic
diet were was discovered that if you
restricted fuel to the brain you could
sometimes treat seizures that nothing
else would treat intractable epilepsy if
they're seizures sometimes would stop if
you starve the brain of carbohydrate
sometimes especially in in children if
typical drugs to treat seizures are not
working sometimes a ketogenic diet is
used but that should give everybody else
pause the calling card of this
particular diet is that it starves the
brain of a key nutrient and quiet sprain
activity is that really what a healthy
person wants their diet to do I would
say no at outdoctrination asks what are
some of the biggest nutrition exercise
Health myths you can think of so the
prevailing view these days seems to be
that carbohydrate is bad everything from
lentils to Lollipops are carbohydrate in
fact all plant Foods along with most
processed foods are carbohydrates so
vegetables fruits whole grains legumes
all carbohydrate and all of the best
diets for humans tend to be rich in
carbohydrate but good carbohydrate is
there bad carbohydrate refined grains
added sugar Ultra processed junk food
yeah that's bad and I don't know myself
asks how do you change your metabolism
how mine is my worst enemy I hate it
good news you actually can change yours
add muscle to your body do resistance
training three times a week when you add
ounces or pounds of muscle to your body
you're burning more calories 24 7. so if
you kept your current eating the same
and worked out doing resistance training
three times a week you would
start to lose weight if your current
calorie intake was maintaining your
weight because you would need more for
those muscles to survive at Allison
McKinney asks are all calories really
created equal I think what you're really
asking is does it matter what the source
of the calorie is and obviously foods
are not all created equal one of the
critical considerations is that if you
eat a wide variety of really Wholesome
foods Foods direct from nature they fill
you up on fewer calories than if you eat
Ultra processed foods here is something
you may not know non-food components
added in with the food now you've got an
ultra processed food those foods are
manipulated in all sorts of ways to
extend their shelf life and to stimulate
your appetite Center and make you
overeat so Ultra processing is bad at
stephanieb789 asks what is a completely
healthy weight because BMI is BS and so
is the weight number body mass index
does not tell you if you're healthy it
does tell you if I on average your
weight is what it should be for somebody
who is your height weight is not a
measure of Health one thing that's more
reliable than BMI or weight to get at
specific health issues is waist
circumference more than 35 inches puts a
woman at increased risk for a man it's a
little higher it's about 40 inches the
fat that that tends to accumulate in the
lower extremities for example the legs
the buttocks much less metabolically
active fat around the middle has a nasty
habit of getting into the liver it
disrupts normal liver function it
impairs our ability to manage lipids in
our blood and it tends to make us
insulin resistant you don't make enough
insulin to manage your blood sugar and
you wind up with type 2 diabetes we
cannot pretend that accumulating excess
body fat doesn't matter but you're
absolutely right BMI is not a measure of
Health at paleo plus asks how legit is
the paleo diet a true paleo diet is
really difficult to achieve in the
modern world the Paleo Diet Paleolithic
diet is about how did humans eat during
the Stone Age first of all you can't eat
any processed foods you can't eat any
dairy if you eat any meat it has to be
game wild animals exclusively the kind
of meat our ancestors had access to was
a lot like antelope about seven percent
of the calories in an antelope steak
come from fat almost none of that fat is
saturated quite a lot of it is omega-3
compare that to beef 35 percent of the
calories come from fat most of that fat
is saturated and none of its omega-3
night and day our Stone Age ancestors
didn't eat that our Stone Age ancestors
got about 100 grams of fiber every day
now the recommendation here in the U.S
for adults is about 25 grams a day but
100 grams a day probably means more time
in the bathroom than your schedule would
allow at cgwa 85 asks I've come to
accept that girl dinner is the main
thing holding me back in life like why
can't I nutrition properly I'm
relatively new to girl dinner but I've
done some searching and I understand
it's something like this it's basically
a quick assembly of foods that you can
easily get your hands on the basic
concept I think emphasizes convenience
we've got some processed meat but we
don't really need that we could have an
alternative to that if you wanted to
take out some of the least healthful
foods but why can't the dip for example
be a bean dip or hummus crackers as
opposed to chips that are made from
whole grains with a very short list of
ingredients there is cheese if you're
going to keep the cheese grapes go well
with cheese some dried fruits go great
with cheese but when you have milk
chocolate and add in a lot of saturated
fat and a lot more calories typically
more sugar comes along for the ride too
but if you traded this up to pure dark
chocolate 60 cocoa or higher it's
delicious it's Rich it's rewarding and
because it's bittersweet rather than
purely sweet it actually fills you up on
fewer calories and now you're having the
Indulgence but you're also improving
overall nutrition so I don't think it
would be that much work to overhaul this
stick with the girl dinner trade up the
nutrition and then girl Dinner won't be
holding you back at flagpea asks explain
the major difference between macro and
micronutrients macro is something you
can see with the naked eye so there are
three macronutrients that make up the
bulk of food they are abundant enough to
be visible protein carbohydrate and fat
micro is something for which you need a
microscopes micronutrients are vitamins
minerals antioxidants that are still
very important many of them are
essential nutrients but they're too
small to see at John Peterson FWS I'd
really like to know from someone that
actually knows if buying organic food
for double the price is actually worth
it slash better for you a great question
we really can't say for sure that it's
better for human health but we have
reason to think so herbicide should not
be part of the human diet pesticide
should not be part of the human diet
antibiotics dose to animals should not
be part of the human diet and if you eat
organic you're avoiding all of those
things produce grown organically seems
to be on average as much as 20 percent
more concentrated in a wide array of
micronutrients than it's non-organically
grown counterparts so that would mean 20
percent more vitamins 20 percent more
minerals and 20 percent more
antioxidants for example if I look at
these Foods here you think about when
would it be more important to buy
organic I like it for the lettuces we've
got Radicchio here I like it for the
carrots I really like it for these
berries so whenever you're not taking a
surface off of food and you're eating it
whole buying organic tends to matter
more at Cartier Angel asks intermittent
fasting is BS it's literally just
skipping breakfast with a fancy name
it's a bit more than that but you're not
entirely wrong there have been
randomized controlled trials putting
them Head to Head intermittent fasting
to limit your calories and no time
restriction but portion control and you
wind up with the same number of calories
the same Foods just is distributed
differently with intermittent fasting
being the difference guess the results
no discernible difference but that
doesn't mean intermittent fasting isn't
a valid tactic for some people it just
works better than thinking about portion
control all the time I mean if you start
your day at lunch and have dinner and
then you stop you're right that that
pretty much involves just skipping
breakfast and the idea is you're poking
a hole in your daily intake of calories
so you wind up eating fewer calories and
that tends to help people with weight
loss and and weight control at ajrendon
96 asks ketosis how does that feel the
ketogenic diet is trying to avoid overt
starvation but mimic its effects when
people go into a state of starvation
they have this sense of euphoria some
people report mental Clarity some people
report feeling very energetic and people
who are trying to stay on a ketogenic
diet experience some of what people in
an extended experience of starvation
feel which is exhaustion brain fog
constipation and a whole host of other
ills so when we're are starving we
actually start to break down our own
tissues we use up our glycogen and once
that's gone we don't have carbohydrates
so we can't make sugar so we start
burning our body fat from my point of
view the ketogenic diet is not a
recommended approach for long term it
restricts many of the most nutritious
Foods the very Foods we know are
associated with both longevity and
vitality at
Luna asks what food drinks should I cut
out of my diet so I'm going to go with
soda source of empty calories source of
a lot of the excess sugar most Americans
eat easily replaceable with much better
stuff water would be ideal but any kind
of Seltzer would be a good intermediate
step we're just going to cut one thing
out of a diet let's cut out soda at
Swiss business asks is going gluten-free
good for everyone no gluten is a
component of some really nutritious
foods like whole wheat whole barley
other grains avoiding gluten is only
important if you're Gluten Sensitive
that means you either have celiac
disease where you actually make
antibodies and you absolutely have to
avoid gluten and then it's very
important or you just don't feel well
when you eat foods that contain gluten
in those instances you should avoid it
for everybody else there's no advantage
in avoiding foods that contain gluten at
nicely asks are you plant-based vegan
and finding it difficult to get the
proper nutrition protein minerals micro
macronutrients now first of all I'm
primarily vegans you get many more
vitamins and minerals from Plants than
from animal Foods there are a couple of
exceptions like B12 and so supplements
not an unreasonable idea protein is not
deficient in plant Foods all plant foods
contain all essential amino acids and if
you find it hard to believe that you can
build big strong muscles from eating
just plants take a look at a horse take
a look at a gorilla take a look at an ox
at poetic dweller asks is the food
pyramid steel real like are you guys
actually eating all these servings every
day this just feels like a lot this is
what we're talking about here it's not
still in use it's actually been replaced
it's been replaced by a plate so if your
plate is taken up three quarters by
vegetables fruits whole grains on
average over the course of the day
you're going to be doing pretty well at
bull spear says honestly I don't know
why I bother eating nutritional labels I
don't know what the nice it is or
why one nutrigrain bar has 10 DV of it
okay our problem used to be
micronutrient deficiencies our problem
today is much more about macronutrient
excess just eating too much of all the
wrong Foods I would say look at an
ingredient list and look for things you
recognize as food well if you're having
a Nutra grain bar you'd really like to
make sure that the first ingredient is a
grain and ideally a whole grain and that
would be a good thing if the first
ingredient in a grain product is
anything other than a grain like sugar
for example you could do better at
mintpoid asks what do I eat pre-workout
versus post-workout macros wise in
general you want to pre-load for a
workout with carbohydrate that's going
to help you fill your glycogen stores
that's the fuel you're going to be
running on during an extended period of
exercise a long bike ride a long hike a
long run a marathon complex
carbohydrates that would be whole grains
it would be fruit for Recovery
afterwards you've used your muscle
you've broken down muscle if you've
worked out intensely high quality
protein and the the other thing that
would be really important post-workout
would be antioxidants antioxidant
compounds actually help protect the
cells as they go through that process of
breakdown during exercise recovery after
so those are all the questions I really
appreciate the honesty thank you for
joining us today on nutrition support
[Music]